so check it out friends do you want to
learn how to go from this to being able
to do this it's not as hard as you might
think in fact I have an exercise I've
been giving to a bunch of my students
that will help you get to this point a
lot faster and it takes a lot less work
than you might think so let me show you
how
Drex here from Drex Factor po sharing
with you the love of pois spinning and
flow Arts to benefit your body and brain
and today we are talking about a
exercise built around po reels that is
going to help you develop freedom of
movement so you can get foot loose and
fancy free with your PO dance but before
we dive in I just want to give a quick
shout out to the Friends of the channel
big thanks to dark monk fire Mecca flow
fests flow toys juggling calling pyate
light toys spinballs and Ultra Troy for
helping to make the videos on this
channel possible you can learn more
about all these awesome companies and
the work that they're doing to support
flow artists like yourself by checking
out the links down in the description of
this video and special thanks to the
non-b business friend of the channel
Becca Becken thank you so very much for
supporting my channel my work and my
mission so check it out this is a trick
that I'm willing to bet absolutely all
of you out there watching have worked on
at some point it is the first po trick
that I ever learned and it's usually one
of the first po tricks that I give to
other people these are reals uh
specifically I'm working with hip reels
right here so this just involves turning
from forwards to reverse with the PO in
wheel plane uh as I'm facing both stage
right as well as stage left stage right
of course the poy are spinning forwards
and Stage Left they're spinning revers
because my dominant direction is
clockwise so this is a really really
really important exercise because if it
begins to get us familiar with the idea
that whenever we change what side of the
PO plane we happen to be standing on
that also changes which direction it
appears that the PO is spinning so say I
can be on the side of the PO plane that
makes it look like the PO spinning
clockwise or I could be on the side of
the PO plane that makes it look like
it's spinning
counterclockwise depending upon where
I'm standing in relation to that PO
plane right so the exercise that I've
been giving to my students is kind of a
tweak on this basic principle here so
rather than going back and forth between
wheel plane positions we add some wall
plane positions in here as well so as
I'm spinning forwards here in wheel
plane facing off to Stage right I can do
a little Tic Tac with my right hand I'll
show you what that looks like as we're
looking straight down the end here uh I
just go back and forth with the right
hand and then plop it down over on my
left hand side here if I'm doing this in
my more traditional orientation I wound
up here that is in a place where I'm now
spinning the POI clockwise in wall plane
and together same in front of me so
rather than going all the way around to
my reverse side I'm kind of pausing here
in between the two and getting used to
spinning the poy in together same in
wall plane notice that I'm keeping my
hands uh shoulders width apart in order
to make sure that the poy have less of a
chance of running into each other we
don't want to keep the hands close
together we want to keep them far apart
here now we can continue this turn by
having my left hand do some Tic Tacs and
finally arriving at a place where both
of the poy are sitting in wheel plane
and now it appears that the poer
spinning reverse relative to me I can
then go ahead and do some Tic Tacs with
my right hand and face upstage with my
POI now spinning counterclockwise
relative to me and then do some Tic Tacs
with my left hand to return back to
facing stage right with my PO spinning
forwards so altogether we want to say go
from facing stage right with the pois
spinning forwards in wheel plane to the
pois spinning clockwise in wall plane to
the POI spinning reverse in wheel plane
over towards stage left and then facing
up stage with the POI spinning
counterclockwise before returning here
to Stage right and by the way if the
words wheel plane wall plane and Tic
Tacs are not making sense to you I've
done videos on all these topics that
I'll go ahead and link to down in the
description to help you catch up so
you'll notice that all of the turns that
I've had you doing thus far all involve
you turning your body to its left you
also want to get down all the turns back
to the right as well you want to be able
to go all the way around to your left
all the way around to your right you
also want to be able to switch back and
forth between them at any point you like
that's going to help you get down that
freedom of movement but wait he says
there's more that's right because
together same is not the only timing and
Direction mode that we can do this
exercise in so let's say for the sake of
argument that as I'm faced over here
towards stage right and I have my poise
spinning forwards at my side I would
just switch things up so that now my
right hand POI is spinning reverse
huzzah I now have the POI spinning into
together opposites once again I can go
ahead and turn over to my left and bring
both of the poy into wall plane in which
case I'm doing what I would consider to
be a forwards butterfly that is the poy
or coming down through the middle and
then I can turn all the way over to
stage left and wind up with my left hand
pois spinning reverse my right hand pois
spinning forwards turn up stage and wind
up with a reverse butterfly that is the
poer coming up through the middle and
then work all the way back over to Stage
right now I can also go all the way back
turning to the right all the way around
turning to the left like so it's
basically the same drill that we were
doing and together same uh we're just
changing things up now so that the POI
are moving in together opposites instead
of together same but the purpose is
exactly the same that is we're trying to
get ourselves used to all these
different positions that the poy can
occupy in each of these different timing
and Direction modes and that is going to
enable us to switch from you know just
kind of awkwardly hanging out in a
butterfly right here to being able to
walk around and occupy all of these
different
places with our po reels pretty cool huh
so that was all of the together timings
now let's talk about what happens in
Split timing so we're going to start off
in Split Time same direction again I'm
going to be spinning the POI forwards
over towards stage right and what I'm
going to go ahead and do is turn down
stage to having my poise spin clockwise
in Split Time same direction now you'll
notice this is slightly different a case
than when we were spinning the POI in
together same namely if we look down the
side of it I'm employing a technique
that I refer to as the lanes of poy that
is I'm keeping my left hand just
slightly further away from my body than
my right hand um this ensures that the
PO are not going to run into each other
as they're spinning past each other in
midair this is a thing that you're going
to just have to train your hands to find
themselves doing whenever you reach one
of these wall plane positions but for
from here I can then switch to having
the Poise spin split Time same direction
reverse over towards stage left and then
up stage I spin the PO counterclockwise
in Split Time same direction again my
left hand is further away from me than
my right hand to make sure that the poy
cannot tangle with each other and then I
turn back to Stage right so stage right
forwards down stage
clockwise stage left
reverse upstage counterclockwise again
you want to get this down turning all
the way to your left as well as turning
all the way to your right be able to go
either direction and it will help give
you freedom of movement as you're
spinning the poy in this timing and
Direction
mode yeah all right and now our final
option here and that is we take that
split time and this time we have the PO
moving in opposite directions instead of
the same Direction so in this case I'm
going to go ahead and turn down stage
and I'm going to wind up in a split time
butterfly I think of this as the
forwards butterfly that's a completely
arbitrary way of labeling it again it's
just the PO coming down through the
middle in front and then I turn over to
stage left I have my left hand poyar
reverse my right hand po going forwards
just like they were in uh together
opposites I turn up stage now I have my
right hand Poise spinning clockwise my
left- hand Poise spinning
counterclockwise I think of this as a
reverse butterfly and then all the way
over again to Stage right you want to
keep that split time feeling going
through this entire thing so again
forwards butterfly or forward split time
butterfly wheel plane split time
butterfly upstage reverse split time
butterfly and wheel plane split time
butterfly again this just gives you the
capacity to be able to occupy any one of
these positions as you're spinning the
POI in this timing in Direction mode
getting this down is so integral to
getting true freedom of movement with
your poy cool so as you're doing this
drill I would suggest doing all four
timing and Direction modes going all the
way around three times in both
directions and then moving on to the
next one once you get really used to
being able to do all of these reels in
all of these different plan orientations
you can switch back and forth between
them and you'll truly be able to dance
and explore the space around you with
them let me show
[Music]
you
[Applause]
cool so try this one out and see if it
helps you out with your own workor I
would love to see more people moving
around out there please make sure to
like comment share and subscribe to help
other people find this video and of
course to help my channel
[Music]
grow this video would not be possible
without my amazing supporters on patreon
in particular I'd love to give a shout
out to my flow p pons who are listed
over on screen right now if you're
enjoying these po Dance videos me
showing you how to accomplish freedom of
movement and moving to the beat of the
music there's an easy way that you can
make sure that more of these videos come
your way and that is signing up to
support them over on patreon you sign up
to do that over at
patreon.com Factor poo every little
dollar there helps me out in being able
to devote more time to creating videos
like this one in the future so if you
want to see more of them go sign up
please and thank you and if You' like to
see a video that I've done on timing and
Direction changes that are integrated
into dance I will go ahead and link to
that down in the description as well as
up on screen thanks so much for watching
make sure to get out and flow today and
I'll see you with a new video real soon
take care now peace